[Music]
deutsche bank provides a suite of
products and services across retail and
private banking corporate transaction
banking lending and asset and wealth
management so devops and cloud adoption
are core of our technology
transformation and the devops research
and assessment in short dora assessment
is key to this on the business
challenges that we face really around
cost and also looking to increase our
in-house engineering capability while we
previously relied heavily on external
developers we are now strengthening our
internal engineering capabilities the
key technology goals for this project
were to reduce risk complexity and cost
while supporting the business innovation
and growth by enabling new products and
services for our customers to this end
we are looking to fully automate
development deployment and controls
enhanced devops practices are central to
this approach the impact of these
changes started immediately and improved
steadily particularly for release
frequency which rose from one release
per month in january 2021 to three
releases per month by november 2021 and
stability also improved with the number
of incidents declining by 40 in the same
time an initial challenge we faced was
that the full dora assessment was being
re-platformed and wasn't available
so instead we worked closely with google
to co-create a lightweight assessment
involving approximately 50 participants
across the bank to demonstrate the
usefulness we then selected an initial
parlous area for a full assessment and
the googlers were instrumental in
helping to select the granularity to run
that pilot up and supporting with
initial briefings and the results
debriefs we also have regular working
sessions with our partners at google as
we scale things to workshop ideas and
plan next steps together with a lot of
asynchronous and collaboration as well
with
our google partners and the dora team
specifically the pilot gave us great
insight into how we could run door at
scale across deutsche bank which we took
into the first full divisional roll out
this also showed the the need for an
option for their teams too small for the
full assessment which led us to develop
a facilitated quick check along with
train the trainer approach for scaling
delivery
we're really thankful to receive this
award from google and to all the teams
who've participated in the door
assessments across db and have really
helped to facilitate real
transformational change we're also
really thankful for our google partners
both on our account and with the google
door team as well